- Hi everyone, welcome
to our daily live stream.
This is something that we
started about two months ago.
Really to, stay in touch
during times of social distancing
and physical school closures.
Obviously, we've been trying
to do a lot of other things,
but we thought it's also nice
to have interesting guests
and have interesting conversations
about the crisis we're
going through and beyond.
I do like to remind everyone
we are a not-for-profit organization.
We only exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I wanna give special thanks
to several corporations
that have stepped up in the
recent last several months.
We were already running at
a deficit before the crisis
and it grew as our server cost grew
and we've been trying to
accelerate some programs forward.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org
AT&T, fastly and Novartis.
And, now we're gonna have a new segment
where I'm gonna bring in Dan,
Hey, Dan.
To just make a couple
- Hello.
- of quick announcements for us.
- All right, so we're super excited
to announce the launch of
our Spanish language U.S site
for remote learning,
khan.co/sigamosaprendiendo
the folks, our team
will be adding the links
to the message boards right now.
It's really exciting 'cause not only is it
for our U.S Spanish speaking folks,
it is also an adaptation of our resources.
So, we didn't just translate,
we actually made sure
that we were adapting
all of our remote learning
resources appropriately.
And then another announcement
we wanted to share
is that there will be no
a Homeroom show tomorrow,
Sal will be on, 'Hey There,
Human' with Rainn Wilson,
better known as Dwight Schrute
on SoulPancake's Instagram
channel at noon tomorrow.
But we will be back on Thursday
for a special Homeroom celebrating
the graduating class of 2020.
So if you know any other
graduating seniors this year,
please, invite them to join Homeroom,
Sal is gonna be sharing
some special messages
and the segments will be highlighting
all the great work that
you all did this past year.
- Thanks, Dan, I'm mildly entertained
and disturbed by some of those
graphics that I just saw.
- (laughs)
- So thanks, Dan.
And so I'm super excited
for our guest today,
Superintendent Alberto
Carvalho from Miami-Dade
who we've known each other
off and on for many years now.
Superintendent Carvalho
thanks for joining us today.
- It's a pleasure Sal,
thank you so much for the opportunity,
look forward to the conversation
and can't wait to see you
in Cap and Gown Thursday.
- (laughs) My mum will
probably be excited,
anytime it looks like I'm
getting more educated.
So maybe good place to start before,
obviously, it will be
interesting to talk about
how y'all have been navigating the crisis,
but what kinda blew my
mind was the first time
that we had a chance
to really dig in deeply
with everything going on at Miami-Dade.
You know, there's a lot of narrative
of large urban school districts,
you know, the stereotype is
that it can be a little bit
dysfunctional, a little bit slow moving.
And I think, you know, I've
told this other people,
when you're not in the room,
something y'all have done at Miami-Dade
it seems pretty incredible.
Tell us kind of the
transformation of Miami-Dade
and where y'all have gotten with things
like graduation rates and other measures.
- It's very interesting, we're
having that conversation now
in the middle of a crisis
because I'm a crisis Superintendent.
I started black back in 2008
- 2009 as Superintendent
at the onset of one of
the greatest recessions
this nation ever went through.
And quite frankly within that crisis,
there was an opportunity
and then we'll go back to,
how we're finding the opportunity wrapped
you know, in today's crisis.
But you know, when I
started as Superintendent,
this was a district with
only 30% of students
were taking advantage of choice programs,
particularly advanced
academic choice programs,
graduation rate
- But what is the choice program?
Just for those of us.
- At Tennis and Magnet
schools, single gender schools,
career academies,
anything but a national
school environment.
So graduation rates were
at 56% district wide,
but behind that curtain
of general performance,
there were some high schools
where the graduation rate
was as low as 35%.
The shame of our community,
we had done nine schools
under a threat of shut down
by the state of Florida
because of performance.
Because for as long as there
wasn't accountability system
these schools had never
posted anything higher,
better than the D or an F.
There were literally,
high schools in Miami-Dade
where zero students were taking advantage
of advanced placement
classes, IB or Cambridge.
And that was reasonably disturbing.
And of course on the natural setting,
I don't think Miami-Dade was
necessarily moving the needle.
You fast forward and the decade later 73%
of our students are enrolled
in nontraditional programs.
That means parents and students
are making choices about
the types of programs,
modality of learning,
something that actually excites them,
if they want robotics, coding,
performing visual arts,
cyber security, there is
something for everyone.
A one size fits none in Miami-Dade,
over 1000 choice programs,
1000 parental options
for kids in Miami-Dade.
Secondly, for the second year in a row
we are an A-rated school
system in the state of Florida,
the highest level of performance.
Three years in a row
with zero F rated schools
graduation rate this year at
90% from 56% and zero school
where the graduation rate below 80%.
The school that used to
have a graduation rate,
at 35% is today at 80%.
And the most remarkable thing
is during that time period
we became better you know,
during times of crisis we had a chance
of reinventing ourselves
into a better version of us.
Discarding a lot of the deadwood slang,
a lot of sacred cows that, you know,
anchor the status quo really well.
Reinvented the school system
through digital convergence.
That's why we were so prepared
for our transition to distance learning
because we passed a remarkable
bond referendum back in 2012
for $1.2 billion,
250 million of which
were spent in technology.
And that was really
revolutionary in Miami-Dade
from curating, developing,
acquiring applications, content,
digital content that's
personalized and adaptive
to ubiquitous universal WiFi guarantee,
expanded bandwidth across the board.
And then the device conversation
we're not using bond referendums dollars
because I don't believe in
mortgaging for 30 years an asset
whose life span is two
and a half to three years,
but we've acquired an
excess of 300,000 devices.
And that's where we are today.
You know, Broad winning district,
one of the highest
performing urban districts
in the country with the highest percentage
of Cambridge passing
rate, AP passing rate.
And when you look at who we are,
a minority district
95% minority, 75% poor,
50% of our student body is immigrant,
80,000 of our kids are
English language learners.
A lot of people would say, can't be done.
But we've shown that the
impossible can become
the inevitable right here
in sunny South Florida.
- And I wanna double click on that
before we even get to the present because
you know, I remember when
I first learned these,
for those of you who are listening,
who are not familiar with
data from public schools
and large urban school districts,
what Superintendent
Carvalho just described
is not usual (laughing).
This is a major transformation
that a lot of people talk about.
What in your mind, Superintendent Carvalho
I mean, even from your from
a leadership point of view
or what other stakeholders
are bringing on the table,
what allowed you to do this?
Why can't we do this in
every city in the country
or in the world?
Or what would have to happen?
Or what should the leaders be
doing to make that happened?
- Yeah, that's the
question I'm most asked.
Everywhere I go, when I give a speech,
when I teach at Harvard,
everybody always asks me that.
And, the answer that I give
is really fundamentally
based on five simple points.
And the conclusion is that this is really
not that hard of work.
It's no longer a skill set
that impairs or prevents
others from replicating these results.
It's really a will set
proposition (laughing)
- [Sal] Will set.
- Yeah, they have the
political courage to actually
embrace the work
and the practice with a
degree of abandonment,
take risks and do right by kids
while sometimes irking the adults,
respecting adults, but
sometimes irking the adults.
And certainly we've done that here.
So the five things, number
one, leadership matters.
And shortly after I became Superintendent,
principals are directly accountable to me.
And I have to tell you that,
and I don't say this with pride,
that I removed, replaced,
demoted, terminated,
promoted 85% of all principals
in the fourth largest
school system in America.
And there's a reason for that.
I was looking for a data-driven,
courageous instructional leaders.
Who are a community minded
and are risk takers themselves
who can navigate complex data systems,
can identify gaps before they materialize
and develop strategies to address them.
And that's the profile of
that leader that I want.
Secondly, the reason why school leadership
is so important is because in Miami-Dade,
and I believe this is a good practice,
we screen teachers, but
principals hire teachers.
So the hiring of teachers, you know,
the building block of
public education is done
at the school site.
So I put a lot of trust in
my instructional leaders,
my captains who are principals.
And that is the second critical element
is effective, strategic,
data-driven teaching
that is differentiated,
that utilizes all the assets we have,
that compliments the leadership style
of the principals we hired.
The third one, is in
fact digital convergence.
And for me, this was our way
of tackling a huge inequity
that existed prior to our work here.
Which by the way, America
came face to face with it,
during this pandemic crisis,
which is a digital inequity.
The fact that across the
country by Zip Code people
finally became aware of
what they already knew
is that there are a lot of digital deserts
and what digital deserts do,
to poor kids particularly
is it limits their ability to learn.
Their learning is limited
in that, bell to bell time
they have in school, why?
They don't have a device at home,
they don't have connectivity at home.
So our digital convergence effort,
which began in 2012-2013,
empowered us with the ability
to actually create a portal of learning
for the most fragile kids,
by giving them a device,
personalized content,
applications and
connectivity if they need it.
And by the way, developing
a parent Academy
to orient parents in assisting
their kids from home.
That's number three.
Number four, is parental engagement.
And by the way, I leave
it for number four,
because I can't change the parent
as much as I can change the child,
but I can influence the parent.
And our launch of the Parent Academy
as a college for parents,
number one, they help
parents help their own kids,
navigate schooling.
Second, empower parents with skill sets,
to get them a job,
in our own school system,
in our technical colleges.
And thirdly, empower parents
in an immigrant community
to be civic minded.
Know their rights, know the laws,
take advantage of the protections
that are afforded them.
But, the real reason
for the Parent Academy
and this hurts the
feelings of some educators
out there in America, is I
want to make parents dangerous.
You know, just like the law of
economics, supply and demand,
you know we all know communities
that are demand sided
in terms their parents,
others are supply sided.
Demand side communities
it's those communities,
reasonably affluent, parents know exactly
where the best school, the best
program, the best principal,
the best teacher, and they
demand that their kid be in it.
Then you have certain
communities where parents
unfortunately don't really
know what to ask for.
They supply with their
children with a hope and prayer
and wish that you do
something right by them.
So part of my theory of action here is,
I want to feel pressure from communities
that have not necessarily
express their discontent,
sometimes with what happens
with our children's school
that's empowering parents.
And then the last element
is effective, targeted, strategic
human capital development,
professional development,
really retooling, re-skilling
the workforce that we have.
Look, you cannot go out there
and trade your army.
By the way, my army is fantastic.
So it's hiring the right people,
but it's also accelerating
the pace that you transition,
the army of employees you have,
particularly teachers and support staff
into a new way of thinking,
a new way of teaching,
a new way of supporting,
a new way of using data,
new way of using technology.
You do those five, and I
guarantee you any school system,
rural, urban, small, large, will prosper.
- Now, those are great.
And I'm getting a lot of questions
showing up on YouTube and Facebook.
Before I go into that,
I actually have a leadership question.
And also, before we
talk about COVID crisis,
you know, you talking
about those five things
and they make a ton of sense.
But I love your phrase the will set,
the willpower to do it, you know,
to go in as a new Superintendent and to,
you know, make some of these changes,
some of them quite dramatic.
It's easier said than done.
- Yeah
- I'm curious, at a personal level,
what went through your head?
At sometimes we say,
Hey Alberto, maybe I'm the wrong one.
Maybe I shouldn't rock the boat too much.
Maybe I should just kinda play nice.
I mean how do you,
'cause I weigh those things all the time.
Sometimes I feel
conviction about something,
but I'm the only person who believes them
like maybe I should just
back off a little bit.
- (Laughs) I'll tell
you a funny story, Sal.
Number one, I do believe in
working at the edge of the abyss
because if you don't know how deep the gap
where our kids live is
and you don't know until
you get really close to it
and you don't get really close to it
unless you take immense risks.
So when I talk about abandonment,
yeah, I'm talking about abandonment
for the position that I
hold, I risk the position.
I try very hard, I tell
this to people all the time
to get fired.
And it is in that precious moment
where you flirt with termination
that's something big
happens for the district.
If it's big enough for you
to make a personal burden,
trust me things will happen.
And that happened quite frankly,
within two weeks of being
appointed Superintendent
goes directly to your question.
Look, remember the nine schools,
they were gonna be shut down
by the state of Florida for performance.
And by the way, these were
all black and brown schools
in high poverty areas.
If you shut down the
school for performance,
the only thing that will be on that street
will be a liquor store upon
a shop may be a church.
And the beacon of hope and opportunity
for that community is extinguished.
I was not going to do that, Okay.
There was a greater chance
of the crown of Spain
of reclaiming Florida than
me giving up on the schools.
So I brought the nine
principles of the schools
one at a time to have
a conversation with me.
And I had a conversation with them,
ask them all the questions.
They had been there for
a long period of time.
And the one question they
all across the board failed
was when I asked them,
why don't you have a single AP class,
AP literature, AP physics,
chemistry, give me something,
AP Spanish.
And across the board the answer was,
you know, I'd love to, but
I don't have kids for that.
At that point, I didn't
have a job for them.
I fired nine principals.
Well, nobody had told me that
over the previous 90 years,
the school system had not
fired nine principals.
And I remember the board
chair at that time,
taking me aside and said,
and saying to me two weeks in,
"You know, I regret voting
for you as Superintendent.
"You fired my friends."
Now it burnt, it was
rough, but I survived.
And once you go through
one of those experiences,
you build resiliency.
When you time that, with
a window of opportunity,
and by the way, those don't
just come once in a lifetime.
They happen, they happen sickly.
We have one happening right
now, a window of opportunity,
then you can get really
crazy good things done.
Not devoid of threat or challenge.
But if you're grounded
in that, which is right,
then you take on the sacred cows,
you take on the political establishment
and you force through
that, which you know,
will actually pay off for kids.
Do I worry sometimes,
I myself not as much.
Sometimes my team does,
sometimes my wife may a bit.
But I feel the community is on our side
we're very transparent.
I tell the story all the time.
The media believe it or not, 12 years in,
I don't complain about the
media, the print media, TV media
because they recognize that
we live it all out there.
So yeah, there are some tough times.
But there are enough
people in this community
who are awake and support the work
and provide a cover for
the work to continue.
- That's super powerful.
Just, you know, you do it right
and the chips fall where they do
even for yourself versus you know,
preserving a job or title
or whatever's expedient.
I think it's a very powerful notion.
- A lot of folks out there do what I do
that never really risked
that much out of fear
of pushing the envelope too far.
And you know, what happens?
They end up losing the job
because the performance never increases.
And so at least, you know,
lose your job doing something
big, bold and right,
that actually moves the needle
because you have greater chances
of actually keeping your
job if the needle moves
because people pay attention.
So you know, that to me
it's my theory of action
and it's worked.
I recommend it strongly
to those who you know,
who don't mind you know,
feeling the pressure
that comes with a territory,
but it's worked for us.
- Alright, that's fascinating.
So I'm gonna go into
some of these questions
and really get more to the present.
You know, Susanna Garcia
Domingez on YouTube is asking,
"Greetings Superintended Carvalho
"what are your takeaways
from this pandemic crisis?"
We have another one from,
I just thought it just disappeared
where a student was asking about
just how you navigating the crisis?
So yet play it out for us.
You know, how did this all evolve in Miami
over the last I guess
two and a half months
when it started to become clear
that we might have to have to close?
- Yeah, so you may find this incredible,
but we did not wait on
the federal government
or state of Florida to tell
us to provide us directives
on how to prepare for what was inevitable.
Actually I remember us back in January,
simultaneously we were
digesting headlines out of China
and I had just watched a series on Netflix
dealing with a pandemic
and I connected the two.
A week later coronavirus
is on my leadership agenda
to be discussed with my cabinet.
And a few weeks later, we were
rating a survey for parents
to determine what the critical technology
needs were at home, why?
Because we put on the board
the worst case scenario
to solve for.
And that worst case scenario is,
all schools gonna shut down,
355,000 K12 kids gonna be home
in addition to 40,000 adult learners,
48,000 employees will be home.
What you gonna do?
What's our solution for that?
So we bet on the worst case scenario,
- And when was it?
Was this in February or January?
- January process...
- January, you having this
conversations in January
no one was talking about school
closures back in January.
- No one, no.
- Well
- We began a contingency plan in January.
February we began to
actually write the plan
two weeks before the shutdown.
We have the first version
of our instructional continuity plan,
which was followed by
an ICP 2.0 and much more
evolved with student and
teacher accountability.
Look, we shut down schools with an MOU
and negotiated agreement
with the teacher's union,
agreeing to accountability,
you know, number of hours
that we're expecting
in terms of responsiveness to students
and connectivity in connection.
Same thing, attendance for students.
We didn't have to do this on the backend.
Before we shut down schools,
we had already developed
Webinars for teachers.
We had already put 100% of our teachers
through professional development,
which was not difficult
because they were already using
the same applications,
the same devices in the classroom
that now the, kids and
the teachers themselves
were using at home.
The geography changed,
but nothing else did.
The survey results empowered
us with the ability
to actually know exactly
who needed a device, who needed a hotspot.
So when we began the
distribution, 119,000 devices
hit the hands of kids quickly,
11,000 hotspots, 100%
connectivity in Miami-Dade.
And by the way, and
this is still right now,
average daily attendance
hold on America 91 to 92%.
That's about one to 2% away
from a typical day last year
around this time.
Because we prepared,
we were not waiting on
the federal government
to say it's time to go now.
We anticipated worst case scenario
and we prepared for it
hoping for the best.
And that's exactly what we're
doing right now by the way,
for the reopening, come August 20.
We are, you know, these days
it's less about strategic planning.
It's more about active strategic thinking
that is nimble, that is
swift, that can pivot
on the basis of environmental
changes in our communities.
And I think leadership
today is having a number
of contingency plans ready jump to,
depending on conditions
as they emerge between now
and the reopening of schools,
however, that happens in August.
And that's exactly what we're doing.
We were not waiting from the landlord
to tell us when to rearrange
the furniture at our level.
We got ready for that.
- And there's several things
I mean, we could double click
on a lot of what you just said,
but I'm curious how you
were able to, so quickly,
I mean it sounds like
one of your advantages,
you saw it coming and you planned ahead,
but you know, just the
devices that you mentioned,
a hundred something thousand devices,
a large chunk of the students.
I mean, it sounds like
you've kind of closed
the digital divide in your community
somewhat you know, not
overnight but over a few weeks.
How did you pull that off?
- Data, data, data.
You know, data is part of
our DNA, is our North Star.
We have an equity mindset.
We knew exactly where the opportunity gaps
were for kids and we planned to address it
in a very strategic,
methodical, procedural way.
And you're right, as far as
the data that we manage daily
and every single day at 9:00 a.m
I get the reports from my senior team
before we start today
via Zoom conversation
that looks at system wide performance.
But then looks at disaggregated data
for the lowest 25% of students
in terms of reading proficiency
for English language learners,
for students with disabilities,
for the immigrant child.
I get all of those reports
in addition to attendance
for every one of these groups.
So we can very quickly address
the pockets of low
performance or the outliers.
I mean, there was a point
where we had students
who were unaccounted for.
Guess what?
We used wellness checks,
even our own police department,
with a knock on the door,
a social worker, a device in
the bag with easy instructions.
We leveraged the fact that
we continue to feed kids
and again, buckle your
seat belt once again.
As of today, we fed
2.9 million meals out of 50 centers,
we do it twice a week for every single day
for every single kid.
No questions asked that
comes to our schools.
But in addition to that,
because we know that some kids live
in really harsh conditions
facing a food insecurity
in their Zip Codes,
we embrace and embarked on
this community feeding project,
not using taxpayer's money,
but through our foundation
capturing money,
then putting small restaurants to work,
to prepare meals to
distribute to the Zip Codes
where we had the highest poverty
overlaid over this grid that demonstrated
the largest concentration of poor kids.
So have we filled or
narrowed some of the gaps?
In some cases, we obliterated the gap.
In many cases, it's work in progress,
but it's what we're
doing now quite frankly,
as we wrap up their school year
and the end of next school year
that I'm excited and if we have a chance
I'd like to talk about it.
- Yeah now, we got a bunch of questions
there from YouTube, Charlotte,
"What is the plan for next school year?
"Will it be digital or
will it be mixed learning?"
Kim darling from YouTube,
"Do you anticipate going back to school?"
Or yeah, so speak to that.
- Yeah.
- What are the contingency
plans you're thinking of?
- So number one, I have
absolute expectation,
I'm the eternal optimist.
Kids will go back to schooling,
Now going back to school and when?
That's a function, since
I'm a science driven guy,
you know, my degree is
in Biomedical Sciences
with a minor in Physics.
I have no choice, It's in
my DNA to decode science
and use it to inform the practice.
So what I can tell you right now is,
what we're doing really in a
very proud and deliberate way
is dealing with,
America will experience
very soon which is,
the largest precedent setting
historic academic regression,
the likes of which the
nation has never seen.
And by the way, it's going
to impact disproportionally
the kids who are always at
the bottom to begin with.
These are, by the way, the
kids who before the crisis
were already in crisis,
which is interesting, right?
There were a lot of kids amongst us,
before COVID-19 crisis they
were already experiencing
a multifaceted crisis on a daily basis.
So for us, this is the
educational opportunity hidden
in this health crisis.
And it begins with two summer sessions.
And by the way, all of our
budget's gonna be hit hard.
But this is my priority,
budget before my board.
Two summer sessions.
The very first one is a virtual session
targeting a student's already identified
on a basis of performance,
on the basis of fragility,
on the basis of their
lackluster connection
during distance learning
on the basis of formative assessment data.
The second summer session may be virtual
or should conditions
improve significantly,
we may bring students into
schools in small groups,
small ratios for very individualized
attention by teachers,
credit recovery, students
with disabilities,
immigrant students and the like.
Then we already budgeted
for and planned for,
the next school year to
start two weeks earlier
for 25% of our student population.
That's 46,000 students opening all schools
taught by selected teachers
who have a high record of success
with these minority populations,
with these struggling students.
Next, virtual mentors and
tutors for every single kid.
Next for 25 schools
that have the greatest percentage
of these fragile children,
one hour added at the end of the day,
for additional opportunity to catch up.
What I'm describing here
is, the opportunity for us
is to academically stabilize these kids
who historically have fallen behind
by the end of the 2020-2021 school year.
Now what will school look like next year?
Guess what America,
since distance learning became a reality
across all 50 states,
parents have had a unique opportunity
to have a front row seat
and observe the whole show.
They have been monitoring what's happening
in their kids' education.
They have made judgments,
evaluated the experience,
they've determined how responsive
the teacher was or wasn't.
They know the level of
engagement of their own children.
And I think parents as a result of this,
are not going to give up that knowledge.
So that's why this new normal,
everybody keeps talking about it's real.
Parents will be more demanding
and I think there'll be more demanding
in terms of expectations
for their children.
But now that they know
that it is possible,
my prediction is, and this
is what we're planning for
in Miami-Dade.
Again one size fits none,
is a very flexible opportunity
to schedule students
and teach students on the
basis of individual student
modality, flexibility and
demand on a parent's life,
the logistics that will
condition our actions,
social distancing,
measuring of temperature
kids going into schools,
having to reconfigure schools
the way for example, you feed
probably you're not gonna
be able to congregate kids
in a cafeteria.
So food will be distributed
to each classroom
like Uber Eats to the classroom.
Unidirectional hallways to reduce contact,
cyclical mandatory washing of hands,
much stronger systems for
illness detection and reporting.
But what I'm excited about quite frankly
is the fact that we
will see in my opinion,
an explosion of hybrid than
blended learning models.
And I'll just gave you an
example, three examples.
Little Johnny because of
parental circumstances
or the fact that he is
a highly social being
wants to be in school 100% of the time.
Our school system ought to
be able to deliver that.
Mary on the other hand
may say, you know what,
my parents, one parent is
at home part of the time
and I'd like to be home part of the time.
So I would like to be
on Mondays, Wednesdays
and Fridays at home.
On Tuesdays and Thursdays
actually at school.
We can do that too, why not?
Then there may be yet another child
who for a whole host of reasons may say,
I actually thrive in this environment
and I want to make school visitations.
I want to take advantage
of some of the programs,
athletics, et cetera.
But I feel safer at least
for the beginning of the year
based on parental concerns,
staying home and learning from a distance.
What I just described,
this sort of a spectrum of opportunity
that is choice driven,
that identifies the needs
of parents and students
and tries to match them
with individualized learning pathways
they are suited and suitable for each kid.
And I think that's
what's going to explode.
It's sort of the new dimension
of choice in America.
- That's super powerful.
'Cause if you take it one
intellectual step from there,
that means that even
the physical experiences
will have to support the
virtual and that to some degree
you're not necessarily bound
to one physical location
anymore, in theory.
- That is absolutely right.
And look, I'm already writing
letters and advocating
based on the experience we've had,
I think state houses and
the federal government
needs to rethink a number of things.
Number one, how education is funded.
I mean I think we're proving that,
having everybody start at the same time
and at the same time for the
exact same number of minutes
every single day in the same
place, doesn't work anymore.
So we need to liberalize
funding methodology
for public education across the country,
so that mandated seat time
is not a mandatory feature
in student funding.
Secondly, the how, when,
by whom and how often
something is taught and what is taught
needs to be looked at as well.
And, I think that what we
have learned under duress,
right in the rush,
can now over the summer and
in months to come be analyzed.
And let's use some of the
learnings from this experience
to actually enhance the student
experience moving forward.
And I think that's reasonably powerful.
- Wow well you know,
Superintendent Carvalho
I could talk to you for a few more hours.
Actually wanna take notes (laughs)
on a lot of this because
what you're doing,
I mean, at a very large scale
with a complex school district
and then there's a lot more houses,
there's a lot of questions.
How are you able to pull this off?
You know, what you're saying
makes so much intellectual sense,
but you know the timeframes
and obviously the dollars,
where are you getting
the resources to do it?
You know, I guess you're
willing to stake your job
on a lot of things.
We talked about that, so that's the will.
I mean, I actually just answer
if you have a couple more minutes.
I'd love, you know, how
are you able to do this?
How are you able to do these programs?
Where are you finding the resources?
You talked a lot of places
like, Oh, we don't have an extra penny,
we're already, you know, over
our heads in terms of budget.
- Yeah, well you know I
think real number one,
let's recognize that the fiscal shock
that our nation is about to experience,
the fiscal shock that a
public educational systems
across America are about to face
is gonna be a daunting one.
But we've been there before,
probably not to this degree.
So, you know, I don't wanna
give a Tallahassee my case
or Washington DC a pass.
During the last economic recession
under stimulus packages back then,
over $115 billion were
appropriated to stabilize
educational opportunities
across the country.
So far under the CARES act,
the current federal stimulus packages
only $16 billion have been earmarked.
And trust me by all accounts, you know,
and we read Moody's analytics
as often as we possibly can.
The prediction is that what's
coming is a more powerful,
longer-lasting economic recession
than the great recession of 2008-2009.
So the federal government
needs to do quite a bit more.
At the same time, I'm
one who believes that,
reductions across the board
don't require leadership.
So even during tough times,
you ought to prioritize that
which is most important.
And that's where we start.
We follow something we
branded here in Miami,
which is values based,
zero based budgeting.
Each year, starts at zero
with the highest priorities
being funded first, everything
else is second there.
And that's exactly what we're doing.
We are preparing for this fiscal shock.
So we turned off the, you know,
the spending rivers long ago,
non essential hiring
stopped, procurement stopped,
renegotiation of private sector contracts
at a discount 10% minimally.
Because whatever the
cost was for something,
a service or a good three months ago,
it's not the same today.
You know as a nation, we
went from 3% unemployment
to over 20% in six weeks.
Everything has changed, which
means we need to change.
So we will face the fiscal crisis
we have and have amassed
reasonable reserves.
We passed two bond
referendum that have secured
teacher salaries in a
very significant way.
We boosted our teacher salaries last year,
anywhere from 14 to 23%
- Wow!
- and improve security.
And that's not in danger because
the funding stream for
that is property tax based,
not state revenue.
So that's gonna remain stable.
Our investment in technology
is gonna remain stable.
Our upkeep of our school
is gonna remain stable,
because we saw the need to help ourselves.
Operations, yes we will depend
on state and federal revenues
and we're working with those as well.
But there's always an opportunity
to prioritize that which
is important in a budget.
We don't believe in 5% across the board,
10% across the board.
In fact, during times of recession,
it is customary for us to
actually augment funding
for certain critical priorities,
like what we're doing for the
fragile student population
rather than shying away from it.
Obviously other areas will have to be cut,
but those are judgment calls
on basis of priorities.
And that's what leaders
right now in America
should be doing.
You know what's most important?
What are the priorities?
What are the gaps, that if you
don't address them right now
will grow dramatically between
now and August of 2020,
making it more expensive for you to engage
in the remediation, which I
don't believe in remediation.
I believe in accelerating
towards every child's potential.
But those are the considerations
and that's how we're doing it.
We're navigating the same waters,
but we have a different
sail, a different rudder
and we're reading the
stars in different ways.
- Wow, well that's super inspiring.
And you know, I think as
we go through tough times
whether it's in a school system,
you're a superintendent out there
or you're just a leader in anything.
I think there's been a lot
of really powerful takeaways.
So thank you so much,
Superintendent Carvalho.
I hope we can continue this conversation
especially over the next few months.
I would love to learn
how all of this evolves,
and I think you're really
on the cutting edge
of thinking through how
this is going to play out.
Thank you so much.
- So I really appreciate it,
you being a terrific partner.
Let's continue to do what we do.
Not only with Khan Academy,
but with the College Board the
Council of Great City Schools
and to all the educators out there listen,
schooling will resume and that
is important for us to be,
a steady stream of normalcy for kids.
Not only intellectually, academically
but also socially and emotionally.
And if you cannot do a face to face,
there are means by which
today using technology,
you can do it from a distance.
And that's what we've been doing.
So good luck to all of
you and talk to you soon.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Well thank you everyone for joining,
hopefully you're as inspired as I was,
by talking to Superintendent Carvalho.
I think, not just a lessons
on where we're going
on the education front but
frankly, leadership lessons
I thought were pretty profound.
So thank you so much.
And as Dan mentioned, we're
not gonna be there tomorrow.
I'm gonna, I've obviously
been a big office fan,
so I'm excited to meet Rainn Wilson
or also known as Dwight Schrute tomorrow.
So that should be entertaining.
And then we'll resume
backup I think on Thursday.
But either way everyone
have a good evening
and I'll see you one way or
the other tomorrow (laughs).